this is Madrid one of the most vibrant
cities in the world now utterly subdued
Spain has told its people to stay at
home to venture out only to visit a shop
or a doctor there are fines for those
who break the rules this is what a
lockdown looks like it's the same here
in Athens go out and you need to take
your passport and have a good reason to
be away from home if you lack either of
those you face a fine but what's notable
is that here and across Europe the
public seem to be backing all these
rules what can I say it is difficult for
everyone but we have to get used to it
for the good of everyone
the first City lockdown in this crisis
wuhan in China at the time that seemed
extreme now lockdowns on mainstream
politics but can it work in Europe this
is the epicenter the red zone of
villages near Milan in northern Italy I
visited this area three weeks ago the
villages were cut off but not the region
only later did a national lockdown
followed a fortnight later and today
cases of the virus growing by just 8%
and lowest on record fewer deaths than
the day before slivers of optimism
nothing more but maybe a hint that the
lockdown in Italy is helping in France
too the streets are deserted much of
Europe now echoes to empty cities and
deserted landmarks these are
extraordinary and restrictive measures
they come in the face of an
extraordinary threat Adam Parsons Sky
News